e
vous êtes en train d'entrer dans l'une
des plus petites rédactions de france
celle du virus informatique situé à
colombes dans les hauts-de-seine
l'endroit est peuplé par deux
iconoclaste olivier sylvain ce travail
officiellement dans la presse magazine
informatique
mais ceux qui s'y écrit leur apparaît
depuis longtemps comme trop lié aux lois
du marché publicitaire et pas assez à la
réalité des produits présentés au niveau
des rédactions ça se passe très bien il
ya toujours des pressions ailleurs au
niveau du service publicité par exemple
qui fait que certains constructeurs ou
éditeurs ont un certain pouvoir sur
certaines rédactions entre plusieurs
produits en a qui sont pas mal outils
sont un petit peu mieux
sans dire que certains sont carrément
mauvais et donc très bien on essaie de
tout ramener à peu près au centre non on
cherche les extrêmes donc quand un
produit est vraiment très bien on va le
dire
evs est très mauvais en valent bien tous
deux titulaires d'une maîtrise
d'informatique
ils ont décidé l'année dernière de
donner naissance à un fanzine qu'ils
veulent sans concession et sans
publicité et vice versa le premier
numéro est sorti fin janvier les s'est
vendu à près de 25000 exemplaires
les collaborateurs du journal
travaillent bénévolement pour le virus
ce qui permet de limiter le coût de
fabrication à cent mille francs par
numéro
si nos deux cyber justicier n'ont pas
encore eu de problèmes avec leur
rédaction d'attache ils ont déjà
quelques-uns avec la profession la
première conséquence ces contrées bien
fait griller vis-à-vis de tous les
attachés de presse et ne soit vraiment
très très peu de produits al'annonce du
journal on a reçu des produits depuis
qu'il est parue c'est ont répondu au
téléphone elle n'est pas là et
rappellera il me l'a envoyé il va
bientôt vous l'envoyez nous en faut
toujours un le virus informatique numéro
2 est en cours de bouclage le deuxième
numéro de voir sortir en kiosque autour
du 22 avril jour où il trouvera sa place
au milieu des autres magazines
spécialisés du secteur
si le succès déclaré du numéro 1 est
confirmée par les lecteurs acheteurs le
virus trimestriels pourraient accélérer
la cadence et paraître une fois tous les
deux mois